ask a very good question which a very
relevant question in these past few
especially in these past few days
especially in Bombay that while you was
doing dawa to a non-muslim and he was
trying to explain religion of Peace when
the Bomb Blast took place he's saying
why are the Muslims blamed though they
are not yet I mean that's a very good
point he said that though it's not yet
proved why are the Muslims blamed and
there was an article which came in time
of India Today morning and the title was
72 virgins was the title another article
when the Muslim clerics went to the
Chief Minister and there was a
conference and a meeting trying to say
that you know there should be communal
Harmony Etc one of the reporters a lady
reporter asked the Muslim clerics that
why are the Muslims only blamed and this
question is always a question mark and
the reply is given very well in this
article in virgins is heading under the
column of personal experience personal
views and he starts the article by
mentioning
that he being a reporter of the times of
India a very senior reporter he goes to
one of these art galleries and there the
person who there in charge he says that
terrorists are not
allowed and they said I was only joking
come inside but then he writes that this
statement though the joke did hurt me
and then he gives the experience that he
had been to America few months before
and they were interacting with the
various people involved the police Etc
in the investigation of terrist activity
and after he explained all the things
one of the police officers told
him that he said that is it mentioned in
the Quran that you will get 7 virgins in
jna for a
person who does suicide bombing or a
person who gets killed so he clarified
there's no such statement in the Quran
at all and nowh in the
text so he gave a counter reply that why
does the media only portray these things
about Jihad and about killing why don't
they mention and why don't they
publicize the saying of prophet malli
wasallam and M Salli wasallam said that
the best Jihad is Jihad of Na is to
strive against own one evil inclination
that's the best Jad so why doesn't the
media portray this indirectly saying
that the media is very much responsible
for
this further in his
experiences he says that whenever
there's any bombing and I give various
names of cities whether it be here
whether it be there whether whe it be
Mali whether it be Mumbai the Muslims
are always the prime suspect most of the
time they are the prime suspect and why
is it that only Muslims are prime
suspect and why we link it with alqa
alqa only Islam that is
there and then he continu and he says
that if such atrocities takes place in
Gujarat a massacre of the Muslims
innocent Muslims which is
undebatable thousands of Muslims were
killed and after that the person who
responsible he's glorified and if he's
going to come to Bombay to give a
lecture against terrorism what will
happen so surely because of this
negative reaction innocent Muslims will
join according to alqaeda that's his
view he gave that if the government
doesn't take action against inocent
Muslim being
killed so who did it is a different
thing when they realize who's the
culprit if the government not taking
action it happens that these people will
join such forces innocently whether
right or wrong and he goes and he
explains various examples he gives and
then he says he talks about one of his
friends and the article is very good it
one of the best articles I've read in
for so many years especially in times of
India and he continu and he says that
one of his friends daughter in
Delhi she took a job in one of the
schools and one 10 year old
student tells her that name was Mariam
that
teacher how can you speak English do
Muslims speak English she was English
teacher so she was so Disturbed that
10-year-old student telling her that can
Muslims speak
English so in short this is how the
media port is and then he gives another
example that one person went to a
building to buy a flat and the agent
told it's very good building he said a
very good building there are no Muslims
here so he gave many such examples the
article is beautiful in the last
paragraph he mentions but when I was
seeing the news channel I saw a Hindu
couple searching for a Muslim Muslim boy
and when it was
inquired that was the boy relative they
said no he was not my relative he was
like my son and then he ends the article
by saying it is such incidents that
recind my faith in India and give me
hope that India again will be a good
country he end the article and I would
like to say that such articles in times
of India reg my faith in times of India
the times of India also will be
unbiased and we have to appreciate s
articles now this replies
to your question also that why are
Muslims the suspect because the media p
is them and the reply you give black sh
to the community is right but only
saying about blackship the answer that I
give is Right But as time goes on the
answer keeps on getting modified answer
is Right n remain the same answer what I
give always that they pick up the black
community and they Port as the exemp
Muslims and they give information about
Islam which is Half Baked they quot the
Quan out of context so this is the main
thing what we have to tell that this
media they influence the human beings
the
media and then we have to realize that
the police is also human being they
aren't something different so they are
bound to read these articles so it has a
impact on them also so many the
politicians are involved for the V bank
what happened in guj nothing but a V
bank if you see the rights that take
place in the country rights any rights
according to me any rights in any part
in any city of India especially Bombay
if the government wants to control they
can do it within minutes any
rights whether it was in Gujarat if they
want but then they take
decisions like what happened just a few
days back they take decisions okay we
won't take any action you be cool you
don't do this because for the W bank
they worried that if we book the culprit
we may lose our vote they are not
bothered about the truth if they really
bother about the truth cpit should be
caught the cpit can be caught
very easily but they take decision
politically if we catch the real culprit
will we get votes or no we won't get
votes so don't catch the
culprit if he catch a wrong
person and malign him we'll get more
votes they'll do it so number one to
blame are the
politicians politicians so the
politicians they engineer everything
otherwise India is a country where our
police is very well equipped very well
armed but fining the control by the
politicians so number one the
politicians number two is the media the
media influences these human beings
whatever articles you read and in this
past few days I've been reading main
newspapers and several not all but main
newspapers and we find in the headlines
Times of India always read Times of
India immediately next day the next day
article came about the blast on
Wednesday Tuesday blast took place
Wednesday article came THD day the
article was in times of India that this
time the city did not come back in it
position like the last blast in
1993 the TRS were empty the buses were
empty and they showed photographs the
offices less attendance the chief
minister said school should not close
but most of the schools gave unofficial
holiday and the full article headlines
came that the city did not spring back
to normaly like the last serial Bast
another newspaper 100% opposite the city
came back the trains were nearly fill
the offices were there and they showing
photogs of absolutely opposite in the
inside news brief you may find yes some
schools did not open but the headline
was so when a person reads the second
newspaper DNA if you read that News the
people are back to normal means whatever
took place in Bombay did not cause a
difference to the mumbay ites they are
for work and they came back if you times
of India only absolutely different
picture two different pictures 100% both
head lines next day you read it comes in
one of the
newspapers that L and Simi are the prime
suspect the other newspapers not
mentioned on your lity see me nowhere in
the newspaper here they blame one person
so when we analyze different newspapers
and everyone doesn't reach five six
newspapers normal majority Le only one
newspaper so I say it is the role of the
media Not to cause any rumor and I'm
told by people news channels you find
that many things when they get get a
news without analyzing right or wrong
they BW it out of proportion as though
he's the male culprit they catch a
person in a bka man in bka knowing very
well he's not responsible but yet they
link it because they want Yello
journalism they want some news so they
link it that as though he was one of the
Prime suspects fine he was doing
something else for his personal reason
if he' gone to meet his girlfriend and
he wore the burka but initially the news
is as though they have CAU the real
culprit without analyzing so by the time
the clarification comes the news comes
in headlines terf come the news brief so
normal people when they read has to be
this person in bka is doing that there
are non-muslims wearing bka that they
don't
tell non-muslim actresses they bka for
the own reason not to be identified that
doesn't come so what we have to realize
it is the media which creates an
awareness so therefore unless we don't
have a media of our own so the point is
that I do agree most of the people
throughout the world at least in the
past few years and especially in the
past few days the suspect if you analyze
go because of the media and where the
politicians
behave and many of times even if they
know that the culprit is a Muslim but if
they feel if we catch the Muslim we lose
our votes they will not catch the Muslim
so the Hindu politician will not catch
the Muslim even knowing he's a culprit
because he knows that if I catch I will
lose my vot so he let the Muslim go on
the other hand the Muslim is not a
culprit if you frame a Muslim and catch
him we get V he does that
so most of the time if you analyze the
scenario see this is a different
situation now last is a very big thing
but where it comes to normal thing the
lower level RS and all surely 99.9%
according to me the police knows who the
cpit is the decision taken by the higher
of authorities they can easily there are
photographs shown by the person who has
done tunch the bus yet he's not caught a
photograph on what witness do you
require now so it is the decision taken
at a high level that should we let this
political party go on or not so if
everyone is truthful that the culit is
whether Muslim or Hindu or non-muslim
he's caught let my seat go if few
politicians down the generation do this
our country will
improve so mainly to the politician they
more bother about their seat rather than
the betterment of the country if they
really think about the betterment of the
country sometime if they take a decision
like Poli take a decision though they
know the culit if you catch him there'll
be RS and all for the betterment of the
masses this decision I don't mind small
mistake someone has done if you catch
him it will blow into snowball but not
bother about the votes bother about the
betterment of the citizens of India or
of Bombay then they take the decision
now we should not take action it's fine
but later on when it subs they should
take action so such decisions taken for
the betterment of the citizen of India
I'm for it but most of the decisions are
for the political vot bank that should
they cat the cpit or not so as far as
the Bomb Blast is concerned we find
several news coming up as you said that
not yet proven what happened 93 blast
yet the judge hasn't given his verdict
many people are yet in jail so imagine a
person is more than 10 years in jail not
yet proved imagine if a person proved
that is involved in certain case how
much punishment he gets 5 years 10 years
15 years
already more than 10 years have
passed so what we have to realize that I
feel most of these things are
politically motivated according to me
that's no opinion and the media the
media to let the paper be number one
newspapers some media are bash that we
are for this political party so they
support that some media they are more
interested that they want something
Sensational so here I would say that if
you that's why I mean I'm a preach Times
of India the times of India didn't give
I mean I'm not Times of India fine
afterward then they may give that okay
the prime suspects maybe but not as
headline like the other
newspapers but they clarify that and
here as though it is in some papers
Mastermind name so and so and so and so
person XY Z so what we have to realize
that we should tell the media to have
restraint so what happen a lay man when
he reads these newspapers he starts
making up an image and imagine same
thing in America Oklahoma bombing what
happened Middle East conspiracy the
person was caught he was a soldier in
the American Army that comes just one
day finish so week coming Middle East
conspiracy when they cat the culprit one
or two days and out of the news if you
haven't read that day you will think
that the Middle East conspiracy there so
what happened the mind is built up so
they cause the damage of 100 points to
Islam the news comes they are not
responsible negative 10 points 10 points
gets condoned 90%
it so what happened even 11th September
today there's no
proof Prime
Suspect alqa I'm not in favor of I don't
know him also I don't know if he's good
or bad
but the thing is that when Yan rley when
she went to Afghanistan she was asked
this question she a British operator
what I use alaa she said I doubt whether
alqaeda exists that's her view I'm not
saying whether it's there or not she
said I doubt whether Al-Qaeda
exists so what we realize that Prime
Suspect Prime Suspect Prime Suspect but
90% more than 90% of the human beings
including many Muslims yet think Muslims
have done
it there's no
proof so what we realize that it is the
media to be blamed unless we have own
media and we able to clarify but one
thing is to be noted that killing
innocent people is Haram in all the
religions including Islam Islam goes a
step further Islam says in Surah MAA
chapter number 5 verse number 32 if
anyone kills any other human being
whether Muslim or non-muslim unless it
be for murder or for creating corruption
in the land it is as though he has
skilled the whole of humanity and if
anyone saves an human being it is as
though he saved the whole whole of
humanity the whole nation and now when
we find when we see that where the real
blast took place in mombay fortunately
unfortunately I don't know most of the
places are close to Muslim areas and
many of the Muslims help the
non-muslims so you may find some reports
but not a lot of
reports but if we see that majority of
the Muslims they didn't think whether
the people who were victims were Muslims
or non-muslim they help them so hardly
they showed such things they hardly
showed this one not twice they show and
in the people that died on the news
Channel people tell me they didn't see a
single Muslim name I don't know I saw in
times of India I don't know the number
of names they about 60 70 70 80 names
are given out of six were
Muslims Times of India released one list
which I read in km Hospital three
Muslims died another hospital one in one
hospital two two were doubtful half
Muslim half Hindu names I give them half
half
so it's either five six or seven I give
six on average so what we realize that
here fine again so no if is the
personage of
Muslims in Bombay whatever it is suppose
10 person names are given or maybe 8
person names are given and Muslim travel
less in first it was normal so what we
have to realize that how do the portr
very
important we seen in the newspaper that
a Muslim family came to see one of the
person who was killed in the Bomb Blast
the moment landed on the airport he was
caught and arrested he was taking 15
hours in the jail not giving water he
came for the funeral of his brother who
was killed in the Bomb Blast he caught
as a suspect of Bomb Blast they ask him
why do you keep a beard what are your
hobbies 15 has they grilled him and a
family was outside on the airport no
water so all these things aren't
highlighted it may come in news brief
somewhere so imagine a person who died
in the Bomb Blast and then he proved his
origin he asked the foreign company to
send facts even after they received that
is working there yet they didn't leave
him only after 15 hours they relased him
so what we have to realize that even the
people in Authority they are to
blame I know their intention they're
also working hard to find who the real
culprit is but even they get finally by
seeing the media even they become biased
so it's our role we as Muslims that we
should have own media and clarify I
don't know if any Muslim media in India
which is really clarifying these issues
on a very intellectual level we should
have our own Muslim newspaper like Times
of India like good newspaper like Time
Magazine like news week and giving
unbiased view speaking about the truth
analyzing the fact that will help convey
the true picture of Islam to the world
hope that